[Música]
mi nombre es penélope guerrero y vengo a
contar un poco mi historia y la de
muchas otras personas que por miles de
circunstancias no tienen oportunidades
como esta podría comenzar hablando un
poco sobre mi vida haciendo es una
especie de esquema pero prefiero resumir
me con que soy una mujer trans de genes
de la frontera y a partir de aquí me
gustaría abordar este momento lanzando
una cuestión
qué es ser mujer
para explicaros que de ser mujer es tan
complicado como para una madre puede ser
explicaros que ser madre no lo que
significan sus hijos para ella es algo
que sientes tan profundo que es
imposible describir tienes que vivirlo
para saber lo que es yo personalmente
siempre supe que ocurría algo no estaba
muy segura de por dónde venía si era por
el hecho de que me sentía atraída por
los chicos o que de alguna forma también
me identificaba con ciertos aspectos que
no correspondían con lo que se esperaba
de mí o del género que me asignaron
cuando nací pero siempre supe que
ocurría algo y eso siempre estuvo ahí
hasta el de al calor o de pequeña por
ejemplo me gustaba mucho ponerme pues
los vestidos de mi madre utilizar el
maquillaje de mi hermana
recuerdo cuando empecé a crecer y el pie
me llegó la talla 38 y todos los tacones
de mi madre me quedaban bien o sea
imaginaos la ilusión que me dure un poco
porque es ella voy por la 42 pero bueno
no pasa nada
por lo tanto llegados a este punto
probablemente os preguntaréis entonces
para ti que de ser mujer por este
tacones vestidos y maquillarse
la respuesta es que no todo esto que
veis aquí toda esta parafernalia mi
maquillaje mis uñas mi vestimenta todo
esto es mi cultura todo esto con lo que
yo he crecido
rodeada de una familia llena de mujeres
empoderadas con una madre recién viuda
que se pegaba palizas de 12 horas de
trabajo
cogiendo carretera todos los días para
sacar a sus dos hijas adelante pero
fíjate tú que a ella no le faltaban sus
uñas arregladas y un poquito de brillo
los labios o mi abuela una señora de 80
años con un ordenador perfecto y unas
uñas larguísimas rojas y naturales las
mías son postizas el caso es que como
digo todo esto con lo que yo he crecido
y entiendo que haya mucha gente que lo
pueda confundir con el hecho de que no
es que a ti el patriarcado te ha
obligado porque hay unos estereotipos
impuestos y es
mira ojalá ojalá a mí a alguien me
hubiera obligado a ser quien soy hoy
porque créanme que el camino habría sido
muchísimo más fácil y es más bien lo
contrario
pero entonces por qué la mujer
transciende hipersexual izarse oa
intentar parecerse lo máximo posible a
ese estereotipo femenino
esto se llama instinto de supervivencia
las mujeres trans somos mujeres por
encima de todo y ha pensado en muchas
personas pero también somos trans y eso
es algo que la sociedad no perdona si
nos ponemos a analizar desde los inicios
de la historia todas estas mujeres han
seguido siempre estos roles y es que
tiene una explicación básicamente es
para de alguna forma pasar desapercibida
para no ser juzgada y señalada
constantemente o para algo tan sencillo
tan simple como encontrar un trabajo
digno
es de reconocer que aunque de alguna
forma lo vemos necesario por lo que os
estoy argumentando no os penséis que a
nosotros no nos imponen tan bien todos
estos estereotipos recuerdo cuando
comencé a los 18 años todo este viaje
como a mí me gusta llamarlo es un
proceso donde tú primero vas a tu médico
de cabecera le explicas lo que te pasa
te deriva a salud mental donde tienes
varias sesiones psicológicas con un
psicólogo hasta que él o ella decide que
eres mujer porque no lo decides tú
después de eso te derivan a un endocrino
te hacen unas pruebas y vuelves para que
te recete tu medicación en este caso las
hormonas este proceso que se hizo tan
rápido puede llegar a tardar entre 8 y
12 meses meses los cuales están no sólo
luchando contra ti misma e intentando
pensar en positivo porque tienes el
autoestima por los suelos porque
realmente necesitas de ese cambio no el
caso es que cuando yo tuve que trasladar
todo mi historial de cádiz a barcelona
cuando me mudé a esta ciudad tuve que
volver a ir al psicólogo entonces pues
nada esta vez yo llegué allí y me senté
era una señora me puso muchos papeles
por delante no
y lo mira y dije [ __ ] pues esto parece
un examen tipo test con su correcto
incorrecto a veces todas son correctas
no me puse a leer y básicamente te
preguntaba un poco sobre tu familia
sobre tus antepasados
hasta que me empezó a hacer preguntas
del tipo de pequeña te ponían vestidos
te maquillas te gustan los hombres
y yo claro yo decía correcto correcto
correcto no puesto final dentro dentro
de ese estereotipo de esa cuadrícula que
me han puesto por delante pero fue
entonces cuando dije qué es esto y si a
mí no me gusta ponerme vestidos y me
encanta ir en chándal que me encanta
también por cierto y si no me gustan los
hombres que soy una mujer desde luego no
me lo está dejando más que claro no todo
esto es lo cuento para que veáis un poco
hasta qué punto se llega a imponer todos
estos estereotipos sin embargo y por
suerte soy fiel defensora de que creo
que el auge que ha tenido el movimiento
feminista en estos últimos años a
nosotros nos ha dado un empujón enorme
porque el hecho de que todas estas
mujeres y géneros salgan a la calle no
sólo a reivindicar sus derechos sino
también a poner sobre la mesa que sobre
sus cuerpos ellas son las únicas capaces
de decidir a nosotros nos ha dado una
carta totalmente libre a la hora de
realizar nuestra transición palabra que
por cierto odio porque a ver yo creo que
consideramos todos que todo el mundo
transición hasta el día en el que muere
independientemente de si eres
transgénero homosexual heterosexual o lo
que sea no que tenemos que pasar por un
proceso de reinserción
social que tampoco sería necesario si la
sociedad se pusiera un poco las pilas y
normalizar la situación no pero bueno
como digo el feminismo nos ha ayudado
mucho porque al final es libertad porque
básicamente yo soy tan libre de
maquillarme como tú lo puede ser de no
hacerlo al igual que ellos están libres
de depilar me como tú lo puedes ser de
no hacerlo porque el feminismo es eso el
feminismo es libertad y sobre todo
igualdad
sin embargo voy a mencionar algo que
capaz de algunas de las personas que
están aquí presentes ya no hay de hablar
y es un movimiento que literalmente está
partiendo el feminismo en dos este
movimiento o agrupación de personas son
conocidas como tres trans exclusión
alibérico feminista o cómo se traduciría
feministas radicales trans excluyentes
para mí básicamente son personas que
dicen ser feministas pero al fin y al
cabo no tienen ni idea del significado
de libertad porque que hay gente ahí
fuera que se llena la boca con el
feminismo y lo único que hace es
ensuciar la propia imagen del feminismo
porque en vez de unir separan convierte
la solución en un problema y es que
estas personas se piensan que además es
un espacio único y exclusivo para ellas
cuando no sea el feminismo es algo de
todos no es una lucha unánime sino
colectiva
y
deja de pensar yo
yo no soy un hombre disfrazado de mujer
que intenta acaparar todos tus derechos
y los pocos privilegios que nos quedan
me incluyo qué es esto porque de dónde
nace este miedo
esto que yo denomino como miedo
realmente no es miedo sino más bien es
un rechazo literal hacia la jen italia
quiere decir si tú no tiene página no
eres mujer si no eres capaz de traer un
niño a este mundo una mujer si no tienes
la regla no eres mujer si no tienes
ovarios para mujer
[Música]
pues así que os digo
que no tendrá un par de ovarios pero
tengo un par de [ __ ]
y estoy muy orgullosa de ello sabe por
qué porque a mí eso no me convierte ni
menos ni más mujer que ninguna otra
mujer en este mundo
hablando sobre esto por desgracia muchas
de las que estáis aquí presentes no vais
a entender y es que hay muchas otras
cosas que no hacen más que reafirmar mi
posición como mujer en esta sociedad y
son cosas como por ejemplo
silbidos pitidos de coches o piropos que
no pido o por la calle por la noche un
poco acojo nada porque se llevó a un tío
que me está persiguiendo hace como unas
tres manzanas
o algo tan sencillo como mirar hacia
arriba y ver ese techo de cristal que
nos cubre a todas
porque yo no me salvo y por eso también
soy mujer
es reconocer que cuando él ha hablado
sobre el psicólogo puede haber sonar un
poco despectivo pero para nada reconozco
y tengo que admitir que la terapia es
algo súper necesario sobre todo en estos
momentos de pandemia estamos de acuerdo
pero cuando comencé todo este proceso
los primeros pasos los de solá no es
porque no tuviese apoyo tenía muchísimo
pero no sabía y es que lo que ocurre que
el simple hecho de o por aquél entonces
pensar en ponerme delante de mi madre
decirle mamá soy una mujer
o sea que era algo que me avergonzaba
demasiado porque ya tiene el colegio no
te enseñan que es ser trans es que tú
descubres que es ser trans cuando tiene
16 años delante de la pantalla de un
ordenador viendo youtube como me pasó a
mí hace 80 años cuando alguien tuvo el
reverendo valor de salir a la calle
decir soy una mujer trans
pero es que por aquel entonces esa
persona que no tenía 16 sino 60 años
recuerdo cuando fui a una de estas
charlas de autoayuda colectiva con
padres familiares y tal en el hospital
clínico de barcelona yo no fui porque
necesitara ayuda por aquel entonces yo
lo tenía todo bastante normalizado y
estable a mi alrededor sino más bien
para que estos padres y madres vieran
que somos personas normales y que además
podemos tener éxito por lo tanto nada yo
fui y llegué ahí y me senté y miré a mi
alrededor
entonces vi a esta persona que era lo
que a mí me habían enseñado que
aparentemente era un señor físicamente
incluso podría haber llegado a ser el
padre de alguno de algunas de las
pacientes que estaban allí ese día
y resulta que ese señor era una señora
de 60 años que acababa de romper con su
vida por completo mujer hijos trabajo
con absolutamente todo porque esa
persona había vivido un engaño toda su
vida había vivido lo que los demás
esperaban que viviese
y ahí estaba yo sentada mirándola y
pensando cómo puede ser esto posible
pero sobre todo pensaba como he tenido
yo tanta suerte
sabéis lo mejor de todo que esta persona
por primera vez en su vida era feliz que
se levantaba todos los días siendo ella
misma y sin vivir arraigada y aferrada a
esa ansiedad ya sea depresión que además
tenía totalmente normalizada
o sea imagínense
por lo tanto nosotros como sociedad
nosotros como colectivos que podemos
hacer para que esto no ocurra
todo comienza en la educación en primer
lugar escolar y en segundo lugar
familiar porque hago estos dos matices
porque un país puede ser un país abierto
se imparte y hablan las clases en las
aulas sobre identidad de género
orientación sexual o si le explica a los
niños que hay un espectro muchísimo más
amplio del que se explica incluso los
libros
preocupéis también puede aparentar ser
abierto porque un pin parental de
libertad un parental es opresión y es
una presión que viene directa de la
familia las tradiciones y las creencias
no se le puede negar a ningún niño de
este mundo asistir a una charla por
ejemplo sobre identidad de género porque
esa persona va a evolucionar va a crecer
se va a convertir en un adulto y el día
de mañana puede o no pero puede que le
ocurre al igual que le ocurrió a esta
señora y se dé cuenta de que ha vivido
un engaño básicamente porque sus padres
pensaron que no era necesario o que
incluso era antinatural
no se le puede negar ni la educación ni
la libertad a ningún niño o niña de este
mundo porque son derechos fundamentales
y hablando sobre derechos no pueden
faltar nombrar todos esos derechos que
conseguiríamos por fin si se llevase a
cabo esta ley trans de la que se está
hablando tanto y sobre también la cual
por desgracia muchos políticos en este
país están en contra no pero es que a
pesar de este patriarcado tan rancio en
el que nos ha tocado vivir
al final el cambio el cambio está ahí el
cambio se nota el cambio se palpa el
cambio está en el aire el cambio está en
la música el cambio está en la política
está en el arte está en la cultura
sabéis qué ocurre que la cultura al
igual que la lucha por los derechos son
imparables
recuerdo cuando hace poco estuve
tomándome unas copas con valeria de gas
muchos la conoceréis por ser la autora
de las memorias de la veneno y estábamos
hablando sobre nuestras relaciones
personales las dos llevamos una relación
bastante estable y longeva con nuestras
parejas y juntas llegamos de alguna
forma a la conclusión de que fíjate tú
lo vacía que está la sociedad de que en
ningún momento en ningún momento siempre
hablamos sobre el tema estético no sobre
el tema de la cirugía plástica sobre
todo dentro del mundo trans femenino
todas estas cosas pero en ningún momento
nos paramos a pensar en lo emocional
si a nosotros nos cuesta mucho encontrar
un trabajo imagínense lo que es para
nosotras encontrar una persona una
persona con la que compartir ya sea un
hogar buenos momentos que te apoyen
se trata de un duelo en el que luchan
constantemente tu identidad tu físico y
también una sociedad con muy poca
personalidad lo tengo que decir
entiendo incluso de alguna forma que se
nos traten como objetos sexuales porque
también hay muchos hombres ahí fuera que
para intentar no hacer muchas cosas sin
que se había muy afectado su
masculinidad nos utilizan y todo esto lo
estoy hablando un poco más por otras
personas que por mí por amigas por gente
cercana que por más que lo intenta no
hacer más que llevarse un palo detrás de
otro detrás de otro y detrás de otro y
todo eso al final se traduce en una
inseguridad enorme y sobre todo en una
falta completa de
la esperanza
digo que lo digo por otras personas sino
por mí porque yo he tenido la
maravillosa suerte de encontrar a
alguien que no solo me apoya
incondicionalmente sino que también me
quiere por encima de lo que la sociedad
pueda pensar sobre mí y eso es un
privilegio enorme y es algo que de
corazón les deseo a todas mis hermanas
ser trans no es ni hormonarse ni me
pasar por mil cirugías ni perseguir un
rol a pesar de que me estáis viendo aquí
yo sea todo lo que estoy diciendo pero
no es eso quiero que hagamos un momento
un ejercicio todas las personas que
estamos aquí y por favor cerrar los ojos
todos y todas
imaginaos esa imagen de ustedes mismos
en un futuro ya no sólo física sino
laboral emocional vuestro alrededor todo
pues ahora tenéis que [ __ ] esa imagen y
sea como sea plasmar la y convertirla en
realidad
porque es que todo esto al final se basa
en ser libres porque al final se trata
de vivir y dejar vivir
porque todos todas y todas somos
perfectamente imperfectos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]